[Musique]
loin des sentiers battus nous avons
choisi de vous faire découvrir des sites
qui ne sont pas référencés dans les
guides touristiques ce soir direction
l'ude au pied des châteaux Qatar une
oasis de fraîcheur un lieu magique et
sauvage léolamberton Frédéric
Gubal c'est un trésor sur lequel
veillent jalousement les châteaux Qatar
un mirage qui hentere lorsque la garique
devient brûlante pour y accéder il faut
se perdre dans les Corbières traverser
des vignes et au bout d'un probable
sentier il s'offre à vous paradis de
fraîcheur taillé dans les rochers le
lieu ne figure sur aucun guide aucun
dépliant touristique pour le découvrir
il faut être initié c'est les gens du
pays qui nous en ont parler par
l'intermédiaire d'un git d'étape
et on nous a indiquer le chemin quoi
puis ça fait des années qu'on vient moi
je suis du Perre Pignan d'accord donc
mon ami là qui est du coin qui qui nous
fait connaître quoi voilà c'est superbe
superbe c'est le mot surgit du massif
des Corbières la rivière a creusé ici
des gorges d roul cascad et vasque
naturel sur environ 1 km plus la journée
s'avance plus la chaleur Devi écrasante
et plus ils sont nombreux à venir se
prélacer dans ce jardin d'eau fra et
d'ombre super lie magique plein d'au la
fraîcheur et du soleil c'est
merveilleux des paysans euh des endroits
comme ça en France ben il y en a pas
beaucoup
et je regrette pas d'avoir fait les
kilomètres Sébastien plat est le maire
du village qui abrite ce petit paradis
comme tous les enfants du coin il a
appris à nager ici et il ne veut pas que
sa rivière devienne un haut lieu
touristique c'est pas comme on n' pas
envie de voir trop trop de touristes
c'est qu'on est sur dans un paysage un
cadre encore préservé sauvage donc
l'idée c'est quand même de le conserver
c'est notre petit coil
secret mais les gens d'ici ont l'âme
généreuse et si vous savez vous d'amitié
ils vous livreront peut-être la clé de
leur paradis
caché